in Washington there's growing confusion
over moves to tighten gun laws after
them this month's mass shootings
Attorney General William Barr said
yesterday the administration will work
with congressional leaders to move
legislation forward starting next month
but president Trump seems to be less
interested after he spoke with the NRA s
chief executive this week we saw Jiang
is at the White House we sure how is the
president responding to the criticism
over his ambiguous stance on gun control
a good morning Anthony president Trump
insists his position has not changed but
it's hard to tell if that's true because
he has yet to spell out exactly what
that position is and how he plans to
tackle gun control over the past several
weeks what the president says seems to
depend on who he's talking to
we're working on background checks there
are things we can do immediately
following that glimpse of assurance at
the White House Wednesday to clamp down
on guns President Trump suggested
current background checks are adequate
we already have very serious background
checks we have strong background checks
the crash adds to a string of confusing
comments the president has made about
how he plans to curb mass shootings less
than two weeks ago he called for
meaningful background checks 17 times in
the span of half an hour you have to
have meaningful background checks I
forget about meaningful and that word
background check mr. Trump has never
defined what he means by meaningful but
he has consistently brought up mental
illness as the root of the problem it's
not the two-sided approach reflects the
many voices in president Trump's ear his
daughter Ivanka has been talking to
members of Congress to find a compromise
while Donald Trump jr. is a known gun
enthusiast and then there's the NRA a
day after reportedly telling its CEO
Wayne LaPierre universal background
checks are off the table mr. Trump used
an NRA talking point warning of a
slippery slope on gun regulations and
you know we can't let that slope go so
easy that we're talking about background
checks then all of a sudden we're
talking about let's take everybody's gun
away
president Trump's ambiguity leaves room
for interpretation on both sides of the
gun debate and that makes passing
legislation even trickier the House
Judiciary Committee is coming back early
from its August recess to work on three
separate gun bills but gale without
consistent pressure from the president
it's a tough sell for Republicans